droits des immigrés dans ses voeux de
nouvel an le président mitterrand
s'engage à revenir à une législation
moins expéditive la loi pasqua en passe
d'être abrogée même si vous avez
l'impression d'y être déjà l'année du
bicentenaire de la révolution n'a
commencé officiellement qu'aujourd'hui
par un lâcher de montgolfières dans tous
les départements français 1er janvier le
droit de rêver visite à l'île du bonheur
guernesey entre l'angleterre et la
france un paradis tout court et pas
seulement fiscale madame monsieur
bonsoir avant d'aborder l'actualité de
ce dimanche 1er janvier un rappel pour
tous ceux d'entre vous qui avait
l'impression que l'année du bicentenaire
de la révolution de 1789 était déjà
largement engagé eh bien non les
premières cérémonies officielles du
moins ont eu lieu aujourd'hui dans tous
les départements français
un lâcher de montgolfières symbole de
liberté stefan mani les joues gonflées
d'orgueil évolutionnaire les facs en
pointe et de superbes historique vers un
siem vont s'élancer montgolfière qui
donne la liberté se veut symbolique
deux siècles plus tard 89 se portent
bonenfant commémoratif est favorable aux
collectionneurs qui pouvaient envoyer à
leurs concitoyens les plus chers une
carte de voeux affranchie d'un timbre et
d'un tampon édité spécialement pour
l'occasion
ces milliers témoignages maternité était
ensuite embarqué pour quelques instants
du vol sur aérostat avant de réintégrer
le circuit postal traditionnel et les
albums des fils at il dit
l'égalité elle était célébrée par la
lecture de la déclaration des droits de
l'homme et du citoyen en chaque chef
lieu de département d'où s'envolent r
aujourd'hui l'une des 98 montgolfière et
pourtant le 1er janvier 1789 il faisait
froid je peuple est fin et personne ne
se doutait qu'un
plus de six mois plus tard la bastille
serait prise et qu'à deux siècles de la
monde entier se mettrait à fêter l'envol
des espérances les plus folles
une nouvelle année qui commence dans la
joie et la tranquillité retrouvée pour
les deux petites filles de jacqueline
valente après plus d'un an de captivité
l'agitation du retour marie laure et
virginie qui n'ont pas forcément il faut
lire vécu leur vie de tâches comme des
adultes réapprennent apparemment
rapidement à vivre normalement tout cas
elles ont déjà retrouvé leur geste
d'enfants pascal deschamps françois
hollande et ce match quelques noms marie
laure et virginie deux enfants qui
dessine comme si de rien n'était c'est
comme ça d'après les médecins qu'elles
vont petit à petit raconté leurs
histoires d'hier leur angoisse car pour
le moment les deux fillettes garde bien
leurs secrets elles ne parlent pas de
leurs nombreux voyages de leur détention
ou de leur mère jacqueline valente
toujours otages et personne ne veut leur
poser ces questions là n'ont pas
tellement changé
par exemple grandi ces bandits et
grossistes
ce ne sont pas deux petites étrangères
non pas du tout quelques mots d'arabe à
et au point de vue identitaire
virgin est très renfermé marie-laure
plus ouverte pour accompagner chacun de
leurs pas dans ce monde qu'elle
redécouvre leur père n'est pas seul des
médecins vont les suivre pendant
plusieurs semaines plusieurs mois
peut-être mais pascal bity sy confiant
trop heureux de les avoir retrouvés vous
avez eu peur de ne jamais les revoir
souvent oui à chaque allusion et
désillusions qu'on a eus promesses et tu
tapes a jamais offert pour marie laure
et virginie les vacances de noël dur ou
un peu plus longtemps pour les autres
enfants
le temps pour leur entourage de les
réhabituer à l'école qu'elles ont
quittée il ya maintenant plus de deux
ans on était encore à propos de cette
affaire que le colonel kadhafi au centre
des tractations qui ont permis la
libération des deux petites filles
déclarent aujourd'hui qu'ils espèrent
que leur mère jacqueline valente sera
elle également bientôt libéré dans son
allocution d'hier soir en présentant ses
voeux aux français le président de la
république a précisé quel était son
programme en matière sociale et
judiciaire monsieur mitterrand veut une
réforme du code pénal qui date de
napoléon 1er en france en très grande
partie en tout cas il est donc selon le
président nécessaire de le modernisé il
va remettre en chantier la réforme
présenté par le ministre de la justice
de l'époque monsieur badinter réforme
enterrait pour cause de cohabitation
entre 86 et 88 le président a également
défendu le droit des français les plus
démunis à ne plus être exclues de la
société refus d'exclusion également pour
ce qui concerne les immigrés la loi
votée sous le gouvernement de monsieur
chirac et qui permettait à
l'administration de décider elle seule
une expulsion va être revue et dès
aujourd'hui d'ailleurs le ministre de
l'intérieur monsieur joxe annonce que
plusieurs circulaires d'application de
cette loi sont d'ores et déjà caduc à
commencer par cette disposition qui
faisait qu'à un étranger en situation
irrégulière
sur le territoire français était
automatiquement renvoyées sans pouvoir
plaider son dossier hervé brusini le
charter pasqua a paru en octobre 86
l'expression ne désignait pas la
naissance d'une nouvelle compagnie
aérienne mais bien la critique d'une
politique à l'abri des caméras 101
maliens venait d'être comme andy
reconduits à la frontière
application des plus rigoureuses d'une
loi qui devait son nom à l'ancien
ministre de l'intérieur depuis septembre
86 les conditions d'accès et de séjour
des immigrés en france se voyait
sévèrement réglementé surtout les
expulsions ne dépendait plus de
l'autorité judiciaire comme auparavant
mais bien d'administration etc préfet
ce ne fut que tôt les critiques de
toutes parts et même malaise au sein
d'un conseil des ministres de
cohabitation où le chef de l'état évoqué
c'est plus extrême réserve à l'égard de
la nouvelle loi
aujourd'hui le même françois mitterrand
souhaite que soit rapidement réviser la
loi de septembre 86,2 fait pierre joxe
ministre de l'intérieur a d'ores et déjà
commencé d'abroger une partie de ces
dispositions
mais le gros du travail se fera à
l'assemblée nationale la question de
l'immigration le sait est
particulièrement sensible au sein des
états majors politiques
elle risque de provoquer force
tiraillements les débats promettent
d'être virulentes
pas étonnant en période d'année
révolutionnaire oui et pour cause de 1er
janvier sans doute de réaction seulement
à ce discours du président ce soit sos
racisme tout d'abord qui se félicite de
l' abrogation éventuelle de la prochaine
prochaine de la loi pasqua et le délégué
général du front national bruno mégret
qui estime lui au contraire que monsieur
mitterrand a donné un tour partisans à
ses voeux de nouvel an en annonçant des
mesures sectaire faisant preuve de
laxisme en matière d'immigration et de
sécurité pour ses voeux de nouvel an le
président avait pour la première fois
dans l'histoire de la république
française choisi strasbourg
symbole de l'europe strasbourg qui est
également le centre d'une polémique
européenne puisque prochainement
bruxelles pourrait bien lui ravir une
partie de ses prérogatives de capital de
la commune
et le président de la république
n'accepte pas cette idée
son discours marque le point de départ
d'une campagne qui va être relayée dans
toute la france henri évite ainsi une
quinzaine de personnalités du monde des
affaires de la culture ventron également
dès demain les mérites et les charmes de
la grande cité alsacienne
et ce pendant 10 jours dans toute la
presse nationale avant une autre
campagne plus européenne bien sûr d'un
côté trois millions de francs offerts
par la ville associée à une poignée de
partenaires privés afin de préserver
strasbourg comme unique capitale de
l'europe de l'autre et sur place des
voeux présidentiels empreinte d'une
certaine volonté véritable coup de pouce
en fait pour appuyer le rôle européen de
la ville
mes chers compatriotes parce que c'est à
strasbourg que rouget de lisle a pour la
première fois chanter la marseillaise le
champ de la patrie et de la république
parce que strasbourg est la capitale de
l'europe
et comme témoignage de son évident
soutien strasbourgeois le chef de l'état
et une petite alsacienne salut ensemble
les quelques 200 personnalités toutes
étiquettes confondues
invité à la préfecture en l'absence
néanmoins remarqué de leurs deux
plaintes président du parlement européen
et marcelino oreja secrétaire général du
conseil de l'europe
mais il est vrai que la diplomatie a
toujours offert tant de nuances qu'il
est souvent plus facile de s'excuser que
d'être présent mais surtout parce qu'à
bruxelles les travaux de construction de
nouveaux bâtiments pour accueillir
parlementaires et fonctionnaires
européens sont aujourd'hui forte avance
et qu'il semble déjà inéluctable pour
ces deux au personnage que bruxelles
soit définitivement choisi le 18 janvier
les députés européens examineront un
rapport déjà quasiment adopté qui
préconise le transfert dans cette ville
du secrétariat européen les voeux des
chefs d'état comme monsieur mitterrand
sont une tradition bien inscrite dans
les grands pays mais ils subissent
parfois des modifications ou des
nouveautés ainsi hier soir américains et
soviétiques ont pu réciproquement sur
leur écran de télévision recevoir les
bons voeux du président reagan et de
monsieur gorbatchev
jean marc et 12
le kremlin à l'heure des voeux oui c'est
bien monsieur gorbatchev mais cette fois
ci il s'adresse aux américains avec
traduction simultanée made in usa
les américains semblent redécouvrir
l'union soviétique et nous redécouvrons
l'amérique les peurs et des soupçons
cède peu à peu la place à la confiance
et à l'amitié explique avec optimisme le
secrétaire général du parti communiste
soviétique réciprocité obligé
téléspectateurs soviétiques auront droit
c'est la troisième fois depuis 85,1
ronald reagan grand charme
en dépit de nos différents nous avons
commencé à trouver des terrains
d'entente
quel symbole que notre coopération en
faveur des victimes du séisme arméniens
ou pour les droits de l'homme et en
pologne aussi un changement du moins un
changement de tonalité
un général jaruzelski en civil et sans
ses lunettes noires qui parle de
dialogue de compromis social de tables
rondes
oui mais une table ronde sans cesse
reporté depuis la mi octobre et à
laquelle il n'est pas sûr que le
syndicat dit sue solidarité soit
désormais vraiment conviés à rome
message de jean paul ii à 30 mille
fidèles rassemblés sur la place
saint-pierre le respect des minorités
leur participation à la société sont
essentiels à la construction d'un monde
harmonieux a déclaré le saint-père
après une prière pour la libération de
tous ceux qui sont encore des otages
le pape a prononcé sa bénédiction de
nouvel an
chez pour les palestiniens ce 1er
janvier correspond à l'anniversaire du
premier acte de révolte armée contis
contre israël qui remonte à 1964 autant
dire que ce week-end et bien l'armée
israélienne était en état d'alerté
maximum ce qui n'a pas empêché des
manifestations dans les territoires
occupés avec pour conséquence de
nouveaux morts et plusieurs expulsions
jacques viau décembre 88 aura été dans
les territoires occupés l'un des mois
les plus meurtriers
deux palestiniens tués hier samedi par
des tirs de militaires israéliens trois
blessées et une quinzaine d'expulsion
vers le liban les palestiniens expulsés
sont originaires de cisjordanie et de
gaza depuis un an 50 palestiniens ont
fait l'objet de mesures d'expulsion ce
1er janvier a été marquée par de
nouvelles violences dans plusieurs
villes et villages sous couvre feu
toute la région de naplouse a été
déclaré zone militaire fermée et
interdite à la presse
de nombreux jeunes palestiniens
manifestaient pour marquer le 24e
anniversaire du passage à la lutte armée
c'est en effet dans la nuit du 31
décembre 1964 qu'un commando du fatah
principale composante de l'olp est créé
au début des années 50
venus de jordanie avait saboté une
importante installation hydraulique en
israël le 1er janvier est devenu peu à
peu une date anniversaire pour les
palestiniens
depuis le déclenchement de l'intifada la
guerre des pierres en décembre 87 327
palestiniens et huit israéliens ont été
tués et en france monsieur théo klein
qui est le président du conseil des
institutions juives s'est prononcé
aujourd'hui en faveur d'un plan de
collaboration entre israël et les
palestiniens car pour monsieur klein
quand on veut faire la paix il faut la
faire avec ceux qui sont en face de soi
suite de la sphère de l'explosion du
boeing de la panam monsieur yasser
arafat le chef des palestiniens de l'ol
paie qui veut absolument se dégager de
tout lien avec les terroristes s'engage
à participer à la recherche justement de
ces terroristes et puis encore le
journal américain new york times accuse
aujourd'hui une société ouest allemande
d'avoir aidé à la construction de l'ue
chimiques libyennes qui fabriquerait
selon washington des armements chimiques
tragédie pour un soir de réveillon à rio
au brésil un bateau mouche sur lequel
150 personnes dont plusieurs touristes
étrangers avaient pris place pour fêter
le nouvel an a coulé dans la baie de rio
dernier bilan ce soir 42 corps repêchés
une vingtaine de survivants seulement 88
passagers restent portés disparus
tentative de hold up hier soir dans un
des restaurants parisiens les plus chics
le pré catelan appartenant au célèbre
cuisinier gaston lenôtre aux environs de
23h messieurs mitterrand barré giscard
d'estaing se sont présentés pour rafler
les bijoux et l'argent des convives sous
ces masques se dissimulait en fait trois
gangsters qui se sont heurtés à la dame
le nôtre et aux personnels qui ont
refusé d'obtempérer dans leur fuite les
trois hommes ont malheureusement tiré et
blessé deux serveurs gens payent eux
christian leroux les clients étaient
nombreux aujourd'hui pour déjeuner au
pré catelan l'établissement de gaston
lenôtre l'un des restaurateurs en vogue
de paris et cela malgré la nuit
mouvementée qu'a connu le restaurant
témoins ces traces de balles tirées par
les gangsters pour protéger leur fuite
il est 23 heures quand les trois hommes
masqués ils portaient des masques à
l'image de giscard barre et mitterrand
surgissent fonds allonger les employés
par terre leurs prêts de la caisse est
sous la menace de leurs armes
or donne aux clients de leur remette
bijoux et argent les événements vont
alors se retourner contre les gangsters
lorsque l'un d'eux tente d'arracher son
colis à une cliente est sous le coup de
la colère de voir quelqu'un qui attaque
une cliente
puis avec ses masques un peu grotesque
c'est ses perruques vraiment cru que
c'était une plaisanterie sauf quand on
est arrivés jusque là bas vous rendez
compte nous vous voyez deux femmes
désarmées course est un type permis
d'approcher des assiettes c'est vraiment
stupide nous dans la salle cassenel peur
c'est après quand il ya eu les deux
blessés qu'eux et on a réalisé que
c'était vraiment des balais que on
l'avait échappé belle parce qu'il ya là
dedans
et partout hold up manqué donc pour nos
gangsters qui n'en porte que la moitié
d'un collier et doivent abandonner la
caisse dans leur suite
quant aux dîneurs ils poursuivent de
plus belle le réveillon après s'être
soumis aux questions des policiers
seul point noir de la soirée deux
serveurs blessé et hospitalisé
l'un a été légèrement touché à l'épaule
l'autre plus sérieusement aux ventes
mais ses jours ne sont pas en danger
ancien sous préfet ancien directeur des
services du conseil général de vendée
monsieur ya cheats s'est donné la mort
hier soir d'un coup de revolver dans le
bureau du président du conseil général
de vendée monsieur philippe de villiers
ancien secrétaire d'état de monsieur
jacques chirac ce fonctionnaire venait
d'être récemment muté contre sa volonté
il s'apprêtait à rejoindre son nouveau
poste au conseil général du cher à
bourges économistes est officiellement à
partir d'aujourd'hui 1er janvier qu'un
certain nombre de hausse mais aussi de
baisse de prix rendue possible grâce à
une réduction de la tva en france prenne
fait et même si certaines de ces baisses
il faut bien l'avouer reste symbolique
elles ne sont pas pour autant
négligeable christophe martel
quand la tva baisse c'est bon pour la
santé de notre porte monnaie
le prix du gaz diminue dès aujourd'hui
de 2 % pour les particuliers les
commerçants et les petites entreprises
et de 7 8% pour les gros industriels
côté transports légère baisse des tarifs
de la sncf mais elle passera presque
inaperçu j'ai plutôt 3 francs de moins
pour le prix d'un billet de deuxième
classe paris strasbourg et un franc de
moins sur la carte vermeil baisse
similaire de la tva pour la ratp
le carnet de 10 tickets deuxième classe
passe de 30 francs à 29 francs 60
pas de changement pour le ticket vendu à
l'unité quant à la carte orange mensuel
elle va diminuer de 3 francs pour deux
zones et de 5 francs pour cinq zones
avec une exception en janvier la carte
orange coûte deux fois moins cher pour
compenser les perturbations dues aux
grèves
les hausses vont apprendre concerne les
allocations familiales qui augmente de
1,1 pour cent en revanche la redevance
augmente vous payerez 343 francs pour un
poste noir et blanc et 533 francs pour
un poste couleurs quant aux prix des
péages d'autoroute
ils seront majorés de 2
5 % en moyenne il est encore temps de
nous rappeler ce soir ce que furent les
grands événements de 1988 nous l'avons
déjà fait hier soir à 20h pour ce qui
concerne la politique étrangère et les
faits divers de la science à la
politique en passant par le cinéma
voyons maintenant quelles furent les
bonnes nouvelles de l'année dernière car
nous avons délibérément choisi de ne pas
nous souvenir des autres
on commence dans l'espace on finira sous
l'eau spectacle magique
ces images ont fait vibrer la planète
terre elles font dorénavant travailler
les scientifiques
ils doivent analyser et interpréter les
milliers de données recueillies par le
cosmonaute jean loup chrétien citoyens
de l'espace avec ses deux camarades
soviétique restée eu 366 jours durant
là-haut la matière se transforme pour
correspondre à ce nouvel environnement
les eaux se fragilise la masse sanguine
se répartit différemment les muscles
s'allonge
les cosmonautes grandissent de 5 cm
environ autant d'effets qui
disparaissent peu à peu
de retour sur terre l'homme cherche à
maîtriser les vols de longue durée
objectif comprendre les réactions de
l'être humain dans l'espace pour faire
progresser la science sur terre
c'est probablement la réussite
scientifique et médicale la plus
contestée de l'année en octobre 88 le
ru486 fait son apparition sur le marché
pilule abortive elle permet aux femmes
qui le désirent d'avorter sans
anesthésie générale ni bloc opératoire
le traumatisme physiologique est moindre
si le traitement réussi c'est à dire
dans 95 % des cas
car il s'agit bien d'un traitement sous
haute surveillance médicale et non de
pilule du lendemain
comme certains avaient pu la décrire
mais il n'ya pas que les nouveaux
produits au tableau d'honneur 88
l'aspirine associé à une dose unique
d'un produit appelé trip tokina se
révèle extrêmement efficace pour soigner
l'infarctus
si la victime est hospitalisée dans les
trois heures qui suivent la tacc en
france près de cent mille personnes
meurent chaque année d'un foetus
on peut espérer que ce nouveau
traitement permettra de sauver cinq à
sept mille vies dans d'autres domaines
la science piétine et pour le sida la
seule prévention efficace reste
l'information en 83 la communauté
homosexuelle s'organise la presse
spécialisée se mobilisent
objectif informer conseiller à prendre
les résultats sont probants de huit
malades sur 10 183 les homosexuels ne
représente plus que 45 % des nouveaux
cas cette année l'industrie lourde
française à l'honneur en 1988 après
pechiney et peugeot qui investissent
brillamment alstom remporté in extremis
le contrat du tgv espagnol
la firme française construira les 24
rames pour un total de 27 milliards de
francs avec en plus l'assurance de
contrôler toute la modernisation futur
du réseau ferroviaire espagnol
solidarité renforcée aussi cette année
avec la création du revenu minimum
d'insertion
la france se met enfin au diapason
européens envers sans eau sans
ressources 2000 francs par personne et
3000 francs pour un couple
l'état aidera ainsi au moins cinq cent
mille personnes pour un coût global
d'environ 8 milliards de francs le prix
nobel d'économie décerné pour la
première fois un français
il s'appelle maurice allais il a 77 ans
et se voit récompensé pour ses travaux
d'inspiration libérale sur la monnaie
la prise de décision en univers
incertain mais l'année 88 a surtout
effacer le cauchemar boursier de 1987
le crack est loin et paris devrait
battre tous ses records de hausse
presque 60 % de progression pour les
valeurs cotées sur fond de croissance
économique très soutenu et d'inflation
douce
une poignée de main sur le perron de
l'hôtel matignon l'histoire en train de
s'écrire autour d'une table deux mois
seulement après le drame d'ouvéa
les négociateurs de l'accord de matignon
engagée dans une nouvelle logique celle
de la paix ce avec une étape décisive
avait été franchi
choisir entre pouvoir travailler on sait
que l'été et s'entretuer
venez sera reconnaître que ces accords
ont constitué un pas important
nous avons réussi à comprendre tous
autant que nous sommes que nous devions
savoir donner savoir pardonner une
évolution spectaculaire est aussi un
succès personnel pour le premier
ministre qui fera au mois d'août le
voyage de nouméa
on appelle cela la méthode rocade la
classe politique applaudie elle ne
tardera pas à se diviser
pourtant la bataille du référendum les
60% d'abstention le soir du scrutin
n'ont pas remis en cause les principes
de l'accord en nouvelle calédonie une
page semble bien avoir été tournées 88
tendresse farouche et dompter celle d'un
ours bart 900 kg de chair et de poils
qui s'impose en star 7 millions de fans
l'ont vu et aimé se battre puis souffrir
en l'espace de sept semaines à coups de
saumon canadien de gâteaux et de poulet
jean jacques annaud a réalisé
l'impossible faire d'un animal dangereux
un comédien 88 souffle de liberté pour
une aventure presque mythique le grand
bleu bat tous les records
les critiques n'avaient rien compris
cette histoire de rivalité entre deux
plongeurs dans l'univers des dauphins
passionne les français luc besson le
réalisateur leur faire redécouvrir cet
élément essentiel trop meurtri et
oublier loup 1er janvier l'heure d'un
compte plutôt agréable à faire en effet
à ce jour le téléthon consacré aux
myopathes a rapporté 168 millions de
francs sur les 185 promis par les
téléspectateurs d'antenne de 90% des
promesses ont donc déjà été tenues et ce
soir de produits 1er janvier la petite
laetitia qui avait ému tous les
participants et des téléspectateurs de
ce téléthon 88 a voulu venir vous
remercier tout simplement pour
que vous avez fait pour eve laetitia oui
alors on vous écoute ce que voulez vous
dire on a tous ces gens qui ont envoyé
leurs dons et qui vont peut-être
permettre d'améliorer les recherches et
peut-être de trouver ce qu'il faut pour
guérir ces maladies de la myopathie
c'est qu'ils ont très bien compris qu'on
avait besoin de l'argent surtout les
chercheurs pour qu'ils puissent trouver
le remède est que ça a très bien marché
ça a été vraiment super parce que où ça
a été même un chiffre plus que l'année
d'avant
alors ça a été très bien voilà tu veux
ne voulait nous souhaiter quelque chose
pour cette bonne oeuvre cette nouvelle
année laetitia oui très bonne année et
puis tout mais mes gars fait merci
laetitia et moi c'est à mon tour à à
vous de vous souhaiter une bonne année
1988 beaucoup de chance en tout cas
j'espère parce que parfois il semble que
cela est trop injuste merci laetitia si
nous ne profitons pas de ce 1er janvier
pour rêver un peu à une très bonne année
quand le ferons nous vous invite donc à
visiter maintenant l'île du bonheur
presque parfait car vous le savez
l'idéal n'existe pas malheureusement
peut-être heureusement d'ailleurs
il s'agit de l'une des deux îles
anglo-normandes entre la france et
d'angleterre
guernesey une île au statut bien
particulier
paradis fiscal mais pas seulement josé
pour la pierre marcel martin ragon
sirène ou robinson lui sert ou aventure
les unes raconte toujours de belles
histoires celle de guernesey et l'épopée
du bonheur plus proche de la france est
pourtant à l'angleterre qu'elle est
rattachée
après avoir été normandeau willaume le
conquérant aujourd'hui elle a son propre
gouvernement fixe ces lois et son taux
d'imposition que la même taille que
paris elle ne connaît ni en bouteille
ajmi grève ni parti politique avoué
qu'il y a de quoi respirer le bon air
j'avais
sur soixante mille habitants 60 chômeurs
le dernier meurtre remonte à cinq ans le
dernier hold up à 25 ans résultat les
150 agents de police chasse
l'automobiliste vos trente secondes de
stationnement en double file 20 à 30
livres d'amande
quand un électeur est mécontent une
téléphone à son député
ici on est habitué à être bien traité
pas de tva sauf sur l'alcool le tabac et
les cent pas de droits de succession pas
de prélèvements sur le capital des
impôts moins élevés qu'en angleterre
pourtant le bonheur à ses limites il ya
aussi et des dotations de fait et bien
pour piller un peu des as sur les autres
et il faut lire les opérations de drogue
il peut y avoir des compensations de
poissons et tu m'aimes aussi je dois
dire que le nombre de divorces dans
l'idée très très élevé et le buy-in
disait on arrive facilement à 200
divorces par an une petite idée comme
celle ci ce qui est beaucoup et le dos
des deux divorces est plus élevée même
communautaire
quand il se fait trop petit quand la
tâche doré se resserre il y a aussi le
voyage prendre l'avion ou le bateau est
monnaie courante sur l'île
anglo-normande 54 banques pour ce
paradis fiscal presque autant d'avocats
pour gérer les 80 milliards de francs
déposés par des hommes d'affaires du
monde entier attirés par la douceur du
climat et rentiers anglais viennent
d'ici passer leur retraite
si le bonheur vous tente il vous en
coûtera 3 millions de francs 1er prix à
payer pour une villa l'argent serait il
donc le secret du bonheur secret de
mandat est un mélange des deux
organiser parce que nous avons société
qui qui n'est pas seulement les choses
financière n'est pas seulement les
choses touristique département veille
agriculteurs ou les pêcheurs et c'est un
mélange de tous c'est c'est comme un
petit micro cause d'implant société et
parce qu'il est si petit il est possible
pour les gens de chacun qu'on est con et
l'autre
cela
une enfant de touba
voilà dix ans
après les banques et le tourisme les
fleurs troisième ressource économique
qui fait de guernesey la roseraie des
îles britanniques vont vous cousins
français
les gars n'osiez feront volontiers
l'effort de parler votre langue
ne serait-ce qu'en souvenir de victor
hugo ironie du sort c'est sur l'île du
bonheur que l'auteur des misérables a
trouvé refuge
le bonheur peut être savoir qu'il ne se
passera rien au détour des chemins creux
et contempler tout simplement le rêve
océans
et voilà maintenant à sa bonne place le
résultat du tiercé qui se courait cet
après midi pour gagner il fallait jouer
vous le voyez sur votre écran le 17 le 8
et le 19 pour l'instant les rapports ne
sont pas encore parvenus et pour le
quarté bien vous ajoutez le 2 comme
c'est écrit sur l'écran
et puisque 1989 est vraiment l'année des
anniversaires en dehors du bicentenaire
de la révolution
eh bien nous fêtons également le
centenaire de la tour eiffel le monument
de france le plus visité avec le centre
beaubourg à paris hier soir à minuit
tout juste le chiffre 100 s'est allumée
et des milliers de parisiens étaient
venus pour l'admirer une nouvelle fois
la tour eiffel voilà ce premier journal
de 20h de l'année est terminée vous
allez tout de suite après retrouver josé
blanc la pierre aux environs de zéro
heure philippe boisseau pour les toutes
dernières informations
et puis ici même demain soir vous
retrouverez hervé claude voilà je vous
souhaite à tous une nouvelle fois et une
dernière fois je peux encore me le
permettre il n'est que 20h30 une
excellente année 1989
bonsoir à la semaine prochaine